hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're talking about
density density compares two things it
compares the mass and the volume of an
object the equation used to calculate
density is density equals the mass
divided by the volume essentially it's a
measure of the amount of mass per unit
of volume and the units of density is
grams per milliliter you may also see
grams per cubic centimeter because a
cubic centimeter at a milliliter are the
same thing let's look at an example
let's say that you have a metal you're
not sure exactly what kind but it has a
mass of thirteen point three eight grams
and it has a volume of 1.5 milliliters
we can now solve for the density that is
the mass thirteen point three eight
grams divided by the volume one point
five zero milliliters if you do this
math it works out to eight point nine
two grams per milliliter you can
actually use the density now to identify
the metal because all objects have a
characteristic density at a given
temperature in this case eight point
nine two grams per milliliter
corresponds to copper you can also look
at densities to compare different
objects for example let's say that you
have a beaker it's full of water the
density of water is one point zero zero
grams per milliliter ice has a lower
density at point nine two grams per mil
that's why ice can float on water
something like copper on the other hand
with the density that is higher than
that of water will sink to the bottom of
the beaker let's also take a moment to
talk about specific gravity specific
gravity is the term for when you compare
the density of a sample like that of ice
or copper to the density of water so we
would say that the specific gravity of
ice is 0.92 grams per milliliter divided
by the density of water which is 1
thus the specific gravity of ice is 0.92
now let's talk about some applications
of density in biology because most of
what we've talked about so far it's
something that you would actually see in
an introductory chemistry class that is
calculations like these but density
plays a big role in biology too for
example gene density gene density is the
number of genes per million base pairs
in DNA population density is another one
population density is the number of
individuals per some units of area and
so something like population density
plays a large role when we're talking
about population ecology stomata density
is another one though mana density is
simply the number of stomata
still per unit area but this time
talking about the number of stomata per
unit of area on a leaf of course stomata
are those openings that leaves use to
exchange gases during photosynthesis and
finally there's something called density
dependent inhibition what that means is
that most cells receive cues from their
environment and when they reach a
certain density in the body they stop
growing and that is how normal healthy
cells work cancer cells on the other
hand they they lack this density
dependent inhibition that is even when
they grow very densely they keep growing
that keep dividing they keep multiplying
and so rather than stopping like normal
tissues they grow out of control
resulting in a tumor so these are all
places where density plays a role in
biological applications that's it for
today's lesson thanks for watching and
we'll see you next time at biology
professors